the greatest gift you can give anybody
is their health and it's as an
entrepreneur the biggest value
proposition you can create one of the
ideas is called Longevity escape
velocity and it's the idea that for
every year that you're alive science is
extending your life by a certain amount
and there's going to be a point where
for every year that you're alive
scientists extend your life for greater
than a year and that's the Holy Grail
all right guys bang bang I've got Peter
here with me Peter I know you've been
doing a bunch of work in the longevity
space and I think that more and more
people are realizing uh there may be
this intersection between their personal
health how long they're going to live
and the quality of their life talk a
little bit as to why are you so
personally interested in longevity and
why you've been spending so much time
money and energy on this space yeah it's
uh it's become a infatuation priority
both as an entrepreneur and personally
as an individual right so I've spent
most of my early life in space focused
on building space companies and then
focused with xprize and Singularity on
sort of moonshine companies exponential
tech companies but it's really been the
last eight years that I've become really
focused on how do we add 10 20 30
healthy years in our lives and that buys
you the bridge to the additional 10 20
30 Health years the story on this well
first of all I'll say that for me it's
the greatest gift you can give anybody
is their health and it's as an
entrepreneur I'm on my 26th 27th company
it's the biggest value proposition you
can create right there no bigger
businesses on the planet than adding
Decades of Health onto a person's life
it goes back to me when I was in medical
school and you know I like to say don't
ever come to me for any medical advice
but in this area I'm focusing uh deeply
when I was in medical school I remember
reading and and researching that there
were species of of organisms whales
Greenland sharks Turtles I could live
two three four five hundred years and if
they could live that long why couldn't
wait and my summation was it's either a
hardware problem or a software problem
and we're gonna have the ability to
eventually fix that well it's this
decade that we're learning uh why we age
how to slow it down potentially how to
reverse it and that becomes super
exciting and so that's really you know
the convergence of AI sensors networks
uh crispr gene therapy all those
Technologies are coming together giving
us the tools to make a dent in aging I
think so when we think of longevity I
think there's a couple of different
schools of thought one is uh hey we can
basically put a pause button so hey you
know you're 40 years old you're going to
pause at 44 10 15 20 years and then you
continue with kind of your life
expectancy there's another that would be
actual age reversal so you're 40 but you
can feel 25 and your body can actually
operate that way and there's a couple of
other uh schools of these thoughts how
do you think about it what is like the
best path forward is it a combination of
some of these or do you think that
there's like a Holy Grail like age
reversal if we can accomplish that
that's really what the ultimate mission
is sure and let me ask you a question
when you're born when you're 20 when
you're 40 when you're 60 when you're 80
. how much do your genes change
yeah probably not that much not not at
all right you have 3.2 billion letters
from your mom and your dad that you get
at Birth and you've got that through the
entirety of your life so if your genes
aren't changing if your software isn't
changing why do you look different why
don't you look like you were you know
when you were 18 and it isn't your genes
it's which genes are on and which genes
are off that matters and that is a
really fundamental question and it's
called your epigenome Epi for the Greek
word above and it's sort of the you know
sort of the Puppet Master if you would
of controlling what genes are on what
genes are off and as we get older the
regulation of your epigenome changes and
genes that should be off are turned on
in genes that should be on or turned off
and so the question is can you change
that can you restore yourself to an
earlier period of epigenetic Regulation
and that's the Holy Grail here and
that's the idea around age reversal
um and so it's been demonstrated in
animals mice rats I think even dogs and
in human cells that are in in vitro in
the petri dish or even human skin cells
grafted onto other animals because we're
not doing this in humans yet but there's
enough evidence to say that there's a
there there and if there is it's the
biggest opportunity and so when I think
about this and I'm you know promoting
this through my companies or my
investments and I've you know committed
for my Venture fund bold we have about a
half a billion dollars two-thirds of
which are focused in this health Tech
biotech space
uh I think about the importance of
just remaining vital and in great shape
for the next decade because during that
decade we're going to intercept all of
these new breakthroughs that buy you the
next decade and then the next decade one
of the ideas is called Longevity escape
velocity and it's the idea that for
every year that you're alive science is
extending your year your life by a
certain amount and there's going to be a
point where for every year that you're
alive science is extending your life for
greater than a year and that's the Holy
Grail the question is when are we going
to hit that
how will we know when we hit that is
that a measurable thing or is that
something that kind of is a a
theoretical that uh we try to we kind of
just trust that science is progressing
and and uh even if life expectancy as
we've seen over the last couple years
May tuck in a little bit in the United
States but really over decades we've
seen it continue to expand and it's a
belief in that versus actually being a
measurable thing it's you're you're spot
on right it is we have to look at the
trend lines over the long term not just
over a year or two during covid we saw
as you said in the United States the
actual Health expectancy drop and for a
multitude of reasons
um but over the last century we've seen
the health expectancy of across
countries around the world increased by
multiple decades and some in some
countries more than double
um I think we're going to know this from
and and really there are multiple ways
to think about uh how old you are and we
have these these clocks these aging
clocks that are based on the methylation
pattern of your DNA but I want to know
how old I am by virtue of my function
right how strong is my muscle how good
do I look how great do I feel how strong
is my heart and all of those and so a
lot of the work that I'm thinking about
right now isn't age reversal Vice some
number on a blood test is age reversal
in terms of how do I feel how sharp am I
you know we're working on this uh this
Rejuvenation this age reversal X prize
that hopefully in 2023 will launch uh
happy to come back and discuss it once
it's when we're able to but in that
regard it's really can we increase the
fundamentals like cognition
you know how sharp do you feel
Aesthetics how good you look Mobility
how strong are you and able to move I
mean these are things that matter a
person when they're in their 70s 80s and
90s hopefully into their hundreds
when we zoom out and we look forward I
don't know 50 100 years if everything
goes right what does that world look
like are people living to 250 years old
are they just look 20 forever uh do they
not die like what is kind of your vision
as to uh it's a big if but if things go
right what could we achieve
so it's really hard for me to think past
20 years from now let alone 50 or 100. I
mean we're beginning to understand
how life Works uh at a molecular level
uh and we're going to unlock an
understanding of why we age and perhaps
why we don't have to uh and so you know
in the next 20 years
um I've been
you know for my last book that I wrote
with Tony Robbins called life force I
interviewed a number of extraordinary
people uh Ray Kurzweil who's my
co-founder of Singularity University
who's been thinking about uh this idea
of longevity escape velocity and also
George Church at Harvard Medical School
and I asked both of them when do you
think we're going to reach longevity
Escape philosophy which is the point at
which science is extending your life for
more than a year for every year that
you're alive
um Rey's answer uh was 10 or 11 years
um from now
George's answer George churches would
surprise me because I viewed him more as
a more conservative academic in this
space and a deep scientist in the space
you know his answer was about 15 years
so our goal should be how do you remain
in great vital State for the next 20
years so you can intercept this now the
Technologies we're gonna have to do this
with are extraordinary it's not just you
know genome sequencing which has gone
from you know three billion dollars and
years to sequence a single genome down
to 200 bucks and hours to sequence a
single genome which is extraordinary
it's five times faster than Moore's law
but it's also AI Big Data that's coming
our ability to really understand
um the inner workings of a cell by being
able to gather a massive amount of data
but what's coming this decade is quantum
Computing and Quantum Technologies to
understand
life at a molecular level it's a brand
new set of Technologies and so
it's we're unpacking and understanding
the fundamentals and again I go back to
why are there certain species of life
that can live hundreds of years right
and I think we're going to understand
that and be able to Port that over to
ourselves so I have two 11 year old boys
I think about them as having a near a
potential for a near-indefinite lifespan
for us uh you know listen I love living
life it's the most exciting time ever to
be alive except for tomorrow and so I
want to see as much of it as I can
when we see so many scientists academics
Etc working on these Technologies one of
the things that we know uh throughout
history is that many times Solutions
come from outside of a certain field Are
there specific skill sets experiences or
maybe Industries where you think there
will be this intersection and we should
look to some of those uh people outside
of just medicine and science that could
potentially have a huge impact here yeah
I think the converging technologies that
are going to enable this are data
science I think it is AI for the next
three to
eight years and then it's going to be
Quantum computation and Quantum
Technologies uh moving forward after
that
um
there's a friend of mine Alex zebronkov
uh who's brilliant uh he is a machine
learning scientist a data scientist that
has entered the longevity field he's
based in uh in Shanghai and Hong Kong
and he's built a company
um that has become a multi-billion
dollar company they just won a 1.2
billion dollar uh
contract with sanofi and he's using uh
AI as his means to do drug Discovery you
know historically drug Discovery was
done by going into the Amazon and
getting plants and and basically being
able to tap into Mother Nature's ongoing
massive experiment by creating you know
of creating different proteins and
carbohydrates and and compounds in
plants that we would look and say ah
this is interesting does this do
anything to human cells uh it doesn't
throw it away does this one oh wow this
one's doing something let's dig in and
see what it does but instead of that
random walk which has been most of
pharmaceuticals up until now right I
mean from Viagra to whatever it might be
um what if you could look at the
molecular uh structure of certain
proteins and use AI to come up with new
structures right we've just seen
a series of AI algorithms out of deep
mind being able to predict
the three-dimensional structure of a
protein based upon its amino acid
sequence right a protein is a sequence
of amino acids and the super Computing
problem for the last 50 years is if I
give you a hundred or a thousand amino
acid sequence how would that sequence of
amino acids the building blocks fold
three-dimensionally into a protein and
it was way too difficult for any
computer to do until it was cracked with
a series of of AI programs and Beyond
cracking a single
protein
you know open Ai and Deep Mind have both
developed algorithms to be able to solve
the sequence of every protein every ever
conceived of so we're getting these
superpowers to understand life
um and I think a lot of the Breakthrough
is going to come data science Ai and
Quantum computing
about science and Longevity most people
see that as a future event that occurs
that will have some magical capability
uh on extending both their life but the
uh improving the quality as well what do
you personally do from a health routine
today so there's things that we can
actually do you know that are tangible
that people can execute on what do you
do
so there's a number of things
um
and first of all it's still the
fundamentals and then there's things on
the edge on the fundamentals I'll start
with mindset I think that you need to
have a positive mindset if all of these
Technologies are coming you need to
believe it you need to see it you need
to anticipate it you need to have a
future for yourself that's bigger than
your past right you can Will yourself to
death and I think with the right mindset
you can Will yourself to life I actually
created an AI algorithm that's free and
available to everybody uh if you go to
longevityinsider.org and this AI scans
the world's news for all of the
breakthroughs every single day that's
going on in uh in longevity age reversal
Vitality science and it looks for the
most uh scientifically valid it create I
use gpt3 and another set of algorithms
and it provides a summary paragraph of
the Breakthrough in easy to understand
language and a compelling image and so
as I read this I go holy [ __ ] oh my God
that's amazing and it's like it gives
you compelling evidence of what's coming
so that you know you want to take care
of yourself in that regard so
longevityinsfetter.org you know it's
great
um and that's the first thing the second
thing is sleep sleep is still a
superpower it is still one of the most
fundamental things we have to do when I
was in medical school I used to think
you know I can get away with five and a
half hours of sleep that was my stable
point and I would pride myself on
minimizing my sleep and still being
functional but the reality is sleep is
one of the most important things we can
do for healthy aging so I now flipped it
and I am shooting for eight hours I
pride myself when I get eight hours of
sleep right I wear my aura ring and I
monitor my sleep in that regard in order
to sleep well I use an eye mask I use a
manta eye mask that I love I can't sleep
without it at this point I use a cooling
blanket and I bring the temperature in
the room down to 64 degrees there is a
direct correlation your body needs to
drop down its temperature in order to go
into deep sleep and REM this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep good sleep
is a game changer and the eight sleep
pod is the best sleep machine I sleep on
it every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself and eat sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep
um and then it's about when I go to
sleep so I my eyes pop open at 5 36 a.m
which means I need to be in bed by 9 30.
I can control when I go to sleep
not as easily when I wake up and when I
do those things I get eight hours of
sleep next is diet and diet is
fundamental
um the key thing around diet is
minimizing sugar our bodies have never
evolved to get as much sugar as they do
um and sugar is a inflammatory it's a
neuroinflammatory and it's a cardiac
inflammatory it's uh when you
glycosylate cholesterol it makes it
sticky and it sticks to your arteries so
minimizing sugar it's not easy but it's
something that you need to do drinking
two or three liters of water whole whole
plant-based diet I do eat some protein I
just don't overdo it I mean these are
fundamentals that are are pretty
repeated over and over again for folks
um and then exercise it's getting our
bodies need exercise it's the most
fundamental thing you know diet sleep
exercise size and for me it's I do a
heavy weight workout once or twice a
week I use a catalyst suit to stimulate
my muscles and do one that way and then
I use a uh another program called
osteostrong which is about stimulating
bone growth and muscle growth and so
those are the the fundamentals on the
supplement side I do a slew of different
supplements there is one other thing
I'll just mention and that's not how do
I put this it's not dying from something
stupid what I mean by that is most of us
are optimist about what's going on
inside our head and inside our body we
don't actually know and so one of the
things that I focus on is
you know can I find out when and if
disease is going on inside my body at
Inception at the very beginning right
we're all developing cancers all the
time people don't probably know that but
you are and it's your immune system that
finds it and zaps it so one of the
things I built uh over the last four
years as a company with Tony Robbins
Bill cap mark benioff's an investor and
we're building out these facilities
around the world uh it's called Fountain
life is the name of the company and
there are 10 000 square foot facilities
uh I go every year in January and I
upload my body meaning I'm fully
digitized full body MRI brain brain
vasculature and AI enabled coronary CT
called clearly dexa scan looking at bone
and muscle my genomics my omics 150
gigabytes of data and the goal is is
there anything going on inside my body
that I need to know about and you know
think of your friend any friends you've
known who passed untimely you know they
something happened while they were
asleep or something they went to the
hospital they found out they had stage
three or stage four cancer it didn't
happen that morning it's been going on
for some time and the question is how do
you know and so this kind of full body
Imaging allows you on to get a Baseline
and then every year make sure there's
nothing going on and then if there is do
something about it right
it's fascinating to understand how
holistic your approach is because uh
what you're really doing is you are uh
attacking this problem from the inside
and the outside which I think uh uh many
people may focus on inside or outside
but putting those together tends to be
pretty uh pretty difficult how much
discipline does it take and you
mentioned mindset earlier uh and I think
part of probably the discipline is the
mindset but but talk a little bit as to
uh is it all fun or and easy or do you
have to have a great degree of
discipline to be able to do this it's
it's listen I I fail all the time and I
pick up and I go again it's like you
know it's like I can have a crappy
night's sleep and it's like damn and
then I'm like okay tomorrow I'm
redoubling I'm going to make sure I'm in
bed at the right time to try and get my
sleep you know listen I love uh sweets
as much as anybody and so I don't beat
myself up but I will redouble you know
the next day and thereafter so it's on
the average it's getting into that
mindset one of the things that's also
fundamental and you know this it's it's
having a community of people
that are with you on that Journey
um and who want that it's if you want to
become if you're overweight you'll
become thin hang out within people if
you want if you're out of shape you want
to get in shape hang out with people who
who exercise in regular time if you want
to have a longevity mindset we can talk
about more about what that is hang out
with people who got that and so I think
they're in lies uh one of the important
elements of this journey it's uh it's
being kind to yourself but also
committed and uh and you know just
not giving up on it and it's doing the
things on the whole
um because you're excited about life in
the future
so this idea of mindset there's many
people who hear that like oh what are
these two idiots talking about this
woo-woo thing right uh what the hell's
mindset uh but one thing I will say and
I think that you probably would share
this but correctly if I'm wrong uh every
successful person that I've ever been
around has a different way of thinking
than the average person now the way they
think is different than each other but
they always have a unique mindset that
uh it feels like puts them in a position
to be successful be resilient do all
these things how do you think about
mindset and its importance for people to
accomplish what they're trying to
accomplish yeah a thousand percent so
here's the question I ask which
hopefully makes it hyper clear if I said
to you what made
you know Steve Jobs uh successful or
Elon Musk or Jeff Bezos from rahatma
Gandhi or Martin Luther King whomever
you want to see as a leader entrepreneur
who's successful was it the people they
knew was it their Capital was it
technology or was it their mindset I I
think everybody would go aha okay I get
it it's their mindset because if you
took away everything else their money
their Capital their relationships their
Tech but they kept their mindset I bet
that the majority would rebuild their
success and rebuild what made them
special in life your mindset is
fundamental it allows you to see
opportunities different than other
people or deal with tragedy different
than other people and if I if you agree
that your mindset is the most important
element you have then the question I
have for you is what mindset do you have
where did you get it what mindset do you
want and how you're going to get that
and so this kind of conversation around
mindset is is fundamental let me let me
take it a different direction to to help
folks understand this when you look at
the field of machine learning of AI and
hopefully this is penetrated enough that
everybody sort of gets oh yeah
um I understand AI is becoming more
powerful there's this thing called
machine learning well the way machine
Learning Works is by showing a neural
net and we'll talk about a neural net is
in a second an example after example
after example like if you want to train
a neural net to recognize cats as Google
did in their YouTube videos years ago is
you show them images of cat after cat
after cat and the neural net shapes
itself be able to recognize oh yes
that's a cat it's got whiskers to tell
years for pause whatever the case might
be
and it learns and you shape it by
example after example well guess what
our brains are neural Nets our brains
are AI neural Nets and we shape our
brains by showing it example after
example
and so the question is how are you
training your neural net what examples
are you showing it over and over again
for most of us and I've stopped this I
won't include me in this one in a second
but most folks are watching you know
Fox and CNN for hours it's on the TV I
call CNN the crisis News Network with a
constantly negative News Network and
it's just you know every murder on the
planet every explosion every despot is
shown to you over and over again like 10
times an hour uh you know and and the
question is if you're seeing all this
negativism all of this fear generating
imagery and scarcity uh driven imagery
because that's what our brain does is
it's typically focused in scarcity and
fear uh you're reinforcing those
mindsets and the question is is that
serving you it's serving
that you know the news network because
they're delivering your eyeballs to
their advertisers that's how they make
money but is it serving you
and so um we have to be careful about
what's training our mindsets
when you see people shaping their
mindset it is easy to say I need to have
a good mindset it is easy to say I need
to avoid negative news are there things
that they can proactively do that are a
Tailwind for increasing it you mentioned
earlier hanging out with people with a
certain type of mindset are there other
things that they could do a thousand
percent I mean so you're shaping your
mindset by virtue of what books you're
reading right uh what podcasts are you
listening to uh What uh you know what uh
posters are on your wall what you know
who you're hanging out with what groups
you're together with so I mean a lot of
the stuff that I've done over the years
is building that out my books abundance
bold the Futures fast when you think
life force for all mindset shaping books
right my the one I did in 2020 the
future is faster you think is a look at
all of the converging exponential
technologies that are creating the next
decade ahead but rather than a dystopian
future like wow these are the
technologies that are going to uplift
Humanity right we're heading towards a
world in which the best Healthcare the
best education is being driven by Ai and
available to everyone on the planet
effectively for free just like Google
right Google for the poorest kid and
Google for the wealthiest kid is
identical as demonetized and
democratized and we're heading that way
uh with uh with the future of uh of
Education Health in a multitude
different areas so it's what are your
communities what are you reading what
are you watching
um and uh and what conversations are you
having
how do you think about mindset in
different macro environments so
obviously uh there's like the peacetime
wartime CEO stuff that people will talk
about in uh in Tech or in business but
if you're not a CEO if you're not a
founder of a company uh it was good
times last year not so great times right
now uh and a lot of that has to just do
with the macro environment and potential
recessions and and those types of things
how do you think about being able to
recognize situation is changing and
maybe even possibly you have to shift
your mindset from one of offense to
defense or back to offense
or
recognize that during times of Crisis
there are extraordinary opportunities
uh it's a judo move one of the things I
like to teach in my um
my abundance 360 community in my in my
books and my my blogs
is the world's biggest problems or the
world's biggest business opportunities
right
um and that if you as an entrepreneur
for those who are entrepreneurs if you
see a problem think
there's a juicy opportunity I can fix
so I think one of the most interesting
things is that
a lot if not most of the successful
companies today were born during periods
of Crisis uh we saw Uber and Airbnb and
even
um you know Tesla and SpaceX born out of
when I say born humming along but during
the 2008 crisis really taking off
um and when there are massive layoffs
that means there are people smart people
available to be working on projects
there's more Talent available
and a lot of the uh a lot of the crisis
leads to new opportunities to be born so
it's a it's a judo move it's flipping
yourself out of the negative mindset of
I'm screwed you know the world's coming
to an end to okay what do people need
now more than ever how can I support
them what can I create that helps helps
this and I think that's one of the most
important mindset shifts that can occur
of course you have to feed yourself and
your family and stay alive and stay
healthy those are fundamentals and if
you're not able to do that that's 100 of
your focus but if you are and you're
looking for as an entrepreneur what do I
do
um there's a lot of growth opportunities
as well during periods like this
so part of mindset to me is ambition and
focus and I've been thinking a lot about
this because we are seeing a number of
people but maybe we'll use Elon uh as an
example where they need immense amount
of ambition and focus to achieve what
they have achieved
but just the same way that maybe a
Michael Jordan and his competitiveness
never kind of gets turned off in
business the ambition and focus is
really hard to turn off as well and an
ambition of focus are two different
things but they generally end up being
somewhat uh uh related how do you think
about these as offensive weapons that
serve as Tailwinds but also potentially
uh things that you know could be
headwinds for an entrepreneur and how do
you know when to kind of lean into them
versus when to say hey I'm an ambitious
person but like I shouldn't go do a or b
and instead I should just focus on the
things you already have on my plate yeah
that's a fantastic question and Elon is
the perfect example
um and I've had the pleasure of uh of
knowing him for 22 years now and calling
my friend
um and listen he's one of the most
brilliant entrepreneurs and Engineers of
not just the century of you know of
probably uh the last few centuries
um The Challenge and and I'll never
forget Elon was on my board of of uh
trustees at The X prize foundation for
the first for about a decade and I got a
call from him one day saying I need to
resign I apologize I need to go focus on
SpaceX and Tesla this was Circa
uh 2010
2012 something like that and uh I was
like I get it and he did go focus on on
Tesla and SpaceX and turned them from On
The Edge to extraordinary game-changing
companies that have transformed the
industry
um and then he started you know
neuralink and uh uh and boring
Corporation and uh and bought Twitter
and and I think one of the challenges
with ambitious entrepreneurs is when
everything's going great and things are
easy and you have extra time on your
hand you think about okay what else can
I do
um and that's fine when everything's
going up but if things are going down
and you've got too many things on your
plate then it becomes really challenging
the alternate approach which folks like
uh Larry Page and Sergey did uh with
Google was create an umbrella
organization like alphabet that had
everything under one organization and uh
and so you had leadership that
controlled the span right the same thing
with Amazon Amazon is doing Health it's
doing food it's doing delivery it's
doing you know uh
everything
um but it's under one uh Under One Roof
so that allows you to diversify but
without having to worry about multiple
brands in multiple different directions
so
I I do think that if you have extra time
and capability and ambition maybe it's
best to grow within an additional
existing organization versus start other
ones
when you see those companies doing it
there is a belief that you need to focus
in the beginning you earn the right to
kind of do this other stuff is that true
I recently have heard other
entrepreneurs starting to talk about
maybe that isn't uh the the way that it
works and we see examples where many
companies have been built with so many
different hands and different things
what's your thought on that currently so
I'm guilty of the more is better disease
for sure I mean uh and
and but I take a different approach
which is for every company that I start
or I'm involved in co-founding I'm not
taking the role of CEO I'm taking the
role as chairman or executive chairman
or a couple cases Vice chairman and
making sure there is a phenomenal CEO
running it and like with the X prize
Foundation right which I served as CEO
for a few decades uh then Anusha Ansari
incredible individual who funded the
first 10 million dollar prize she flew
private to the space station and she
became our CEO four years ago and I took
a role as executive chairman but I can
swoop in work with her come up with a
new idea launch it within the X prize
but she is running the show it's
everybody reports to her and she's the
final decision maker right in uh
Fountain life one of my longevity
companies that is doing the uh uh the
you know uh annual uploading of Imaging
and Therapeutics to make sure that
you're in the healthiest State again I'm
serving as executive chairman there but
Dr Bill Capp is a CEO and does an
amazing job at Fountain so I in that way
I can keep my sort of diversity mindset
alive and I can cross pollinate so you
know I run a singularity University I'm
the executive founder there but Eric
Anderson runs it uh as the uh as the
executive chairman and then abundance
360 I sort of oversee it but I've got
Julie van amarongen running it day to
day so I can cross pollinate between
these and bring resources from one to
the other but each one of them has a
person responsible for the p l and who
I'll make suggestions to I'll
co-conspire with them but they're
running the show
how do you pick them how do you know
they're the right person how do you know
that they're good at what you need them
to do
so
the and I asked when I did a uh I did a
podcast with Elon for my moonshots and
mindset show
um and I asked him that question as well
and he never answered me on it that was
like amazed at at how he because he
started somebody comments how do you get
how do you find your CEOs and Captain
hammering for that you didn't answer me
yes because he just makes himself the
CEO well and that's a problem right and
I've had conversations with him where he
said listen I could find someone to be
the CEO of Tesla so I can focus on
SpaceX I would and hopefully and and you
know when the company is stable and it's
obviously going up and down and it
hasn't fully stabilized I would never
bet against Tesla or never bet against
SpaceX or Elon in a thousand years and I
you know I do that with my stock
portfolio but um for me
uh I find the CEO in a couple of ways
one is
I may acquire a company that's operating
really well
um and in that acquisition or merge with
a company that's operating really well
and Elevate that individual who is
running that company to CEO and I'll
take an executive chairman role the best
predictor of an individual's future
potential is what they've done in the
past 100 right
um unless they're a brand new uh founder
like uh Zuckerberg or in the early days
of of Elon or Steve Jobs whatever the
case might be and by the way a lot of
the biggest most successful tech
companies in the world were first-time
Founders right Bill Gates
um and so you've gotta you've got to
account for that but if you're looking
to bring in a CEO you want someone who
has an entrepreneurial bent which means
they probably have started things on
their own and you know taking someone
who's been a Hired Gun inside a lot
larger company and making them a CEO of
your company if it's still in its
entrepreneurial it's building it's
growing it's creating
it's a kind of a mismatch so I'm looking
for someone who's got entrepreneurial
chops maybe they've just exited their
company and they're looking to start
their next one I'm saying come on in the
water's warm join me let's go do this or
like I said acquiring them or merging
with them if it's an equal and then
giving them the home and supporting them
to do well does that make sense it makes
complete sense and I guess part of it
also is uh when you're acquiring a
company when you're merging with a
company you've been able to see them
operate to some degree right it's kind
of like a little try before you buy if
you will but also on top of that uh it
sounds like most of the people that you
are bringing in to run these
organizations uh are not a 22 year old
who's just starting although we do see
the outlier uh kind of outcomes from
them as you mentioned I think the
average age of a successful
multi-billion dollar founder is like 43
or something I forget the exact number
but it's not it's experience is a key
piece to
uh to being successful uh on average
yeah yes and they also start when
they're 30. uh I mean you know the
challenge is all of us think about these
overnight successes well it's overnight
success after 11 years of hard work you
know uh and and it took a while to get
become a a billionaire or a billionaire
founder
um
I know a lot of my most successful
Ventures are people don't just know the
early days right uh Tesla Uber Airbnb
all these companies took a while to get
to where they are
um but you're right it's
experience is key there there's one
other place you can go look and it's was
there an individual who's part of a
founding team uh who
is you know a CEO or a SVP or a you know
uh some but not the CEO of that founding
team but he's got the chops where she's
got the chops and uh and that
entrepreneurial mindset because it is a
mindset it is a hunger uh to go and make
a dent in the universe to use Steve
Jobs's words
um and that that is a mindset that grows
in you and it comes so one one of the
things that I that I do is I focus on um
uh what is your MTP what is your massive
transformative purpose
right uh and when you are when you
connect with your MTP and it's it's got
to be powered by emotional energy it's
got to be powered by this like super
positive energy of awe and amazement
like I can't wait to make this happen
this is going to be extraordinary or
it's powered by this pain like I refuse
to let this go on in the world I am
going to solve this problem if it's the
last thing I do right it's got to come
from that emotional energy and when you
can when you can uh describe your
massive transform into purpose it then
becomes a canvas upon which you're going
to take your moonshots and your moon
shots or targets uh in the direction of
that purpose
one last thing I want to talk to you
about is Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies uh
you have always I think hung your hat on
Innovative Technologies on Bold ambition
uh in kind of a technology driven future
uh an area that people are very
interested in is obviously Bitcoin and
uh the crypto world what are your
current thoughts there we're recording
this while uh we're in the middle of a
huge crash is your connection uh over or
are you still excited no no I'm I remain
committed to and I'll say the same thing
I've always said this is not my our
expertise I turn to people like Michael
Saylor who I've had on my podcast and
who I've uh known for COD 40 years who
were fraternity Brothers together in MIT
um and we live next to each other and
he's brilliant uh and you know he is a
Bitcoin maximalist and on this last sort
of FTX downturn I I bought into Bitcoin
once again I do believe in it in the
long term and I'm willing to buy in and
hold it for the long term I think that
the fundamentals are there and I think
it will be adapted uh in a multitude of
different institutional settings and
governmental settings over the decades
ahead especially as the speed of
Technology makes traditional government
structures
in need of the Velocity that we're going
to see with Bitcoin and lightning
um and the turbulence that comes with uh
with these converging exponentials as
we're transforming the energy ecosystem
we're going from you know oil and and
gas petroleum-based systems uh to uh to
solar and eventually you know solar wind
and fusion
um and it's going to cause uh turmoil
and upset but I think Bitcoin is a
stabilizing Factor so you know I'm
probably
uh 90 Bitcoin 10 ethereum in my Holdings
um and I uh I haven't sold any Bitcoin
since my since I started buying and I'm
just slowly accumulating over time now
it's not to say that I don't sell and
repurchase you know because the law
allows you to do that and get the tax
benefits of a wash sale like that at
least it does for the moment we'll see
if that if that changes but
um when I think about the arguments that
Mike seller makes about the long-term
value of different assets and asset
classes
um it makes a thousand percent sense to
me
as you look at this technology I know
one of the things that we talked about
in the science and medicine field is
this convergence of Technologies is that
your belief in things like AI ml Bitcoin
kind of these other software-based uh
technologies that you think a lot of
those will converge and kind of create I
don't know make kind of a tech Utopia or
some sort of like uh you know brighter
future
well so it is and has been and people
just don't recognize it right we have
seen uh extreme poverty on the planet
you know go from like 90 to under 10 uh
it used to be throughout all history
that you know if you go back hundreds of
years to thousands of years it was the
king and the Queen on the hilltop right
the Pharaoh the emperor whatever it
might be and 99.999 of people in
absolute squalor supporting that that
king or queen which barely had anything
that you could hold a candle do today
right didn't have lights or flushing
toilets or or transport and so forth it
was but they had the best they could
today we're living in a world where even
the poorest people on the planet have
access to uh energy Communications uh
knowledge right Google's demonetized and
democratized access to information we're
seeing 4 40 dollar smartphones allowing
people to have access to near infinite
entertainment and knowledge and and
we're heading towards a world and it
isn't here yet but we're heading towards
a world where we're going to provide
folks with access to the best health
care not delivered by your physician but
by delivered by an AI at the cost of
effectively electricity right there's
about 5 000 medical journal articles
published per day per day how many has
your doctor read right
um probably maybe one if if you're lucky
and they had time over coffee your AI
will have accessed all of them so we're
going to see AI becoming the best
diagnostician a robotic surgeon being
the best surgeon out there again for the
cost of electricity and the capital
expense not here yet but we're going to
be seeing that in the next decade 20
years is going to be in the next five
years I think
it will become
malpracticed to do diagnostics without
AI in Loop um I was having dinner with
Reed Hoffman founder of LinkedIn
um a week ago and he was saying listen
the next five years we're going to have
an AI co-pilot for every profession and
I think that's true your AI is going to
support you if you're a writer a
musician a account a lawyer AI is going
to support you to do your job more
thoroughly and and better and
ultimately we're demonetizing and
democratizing every aspect of our life
and and so it is it's coming you know uh
we used to think about socialism as the
means by which governments would take
care of you right there were socialist
governments so we're going to take care
of you provide you food water health and
so forth well we're heading for
um and I'm a I would describe myself as
a Libertarian capitalist right I love
starting companies and um you know
that's who I am but I think we're going
to have a version of uh of technology
technology socialism where technology is
taking care of you technology is
educating providing Health uh we're
going to see the the best food
healthiest food is going to be stem cell
grown Meats fish chicken beef and
vertical forming that's produced in
downtown New York Detroit Chicago
Nairobi wherever it might be where it's
healthier cheaper and available to you
faster from the farm to the table than
ever before all of these things are
changing
my last question for you revolves around
the content that you consume uh you
mentioned earlier it helps with mindset
obviously you're you're very well versed
on a lot of different Technologies what
do you read on a day-to-day basis
um and are there certain mechanisms that
you have I know you mentioned longevity
Insider as one place where people can
get information but how do you kind of
sift through all the information that's
out there in order to read the things
that you think are the highest impact so
uh I
so part of the work that I do
um as as you do is I educate and I I do
that through my abundance 360 and my my
books my blogs and such and so I'm
constantly consuming information and I I
got to I originally I used to hire
people who would be constantly consuming
and summarizing and feeding me stuff and
it got to a point where it was
impossible keep up with it and so about
four years ago I hired a couple of
really smart AI guys and we started a
company called futurescope and built in
AI that builds specialized AI search
engines
um and uh so
longevityinsider.org the dot org part is
important important if it wants to get
it is it's free and again that's my AI
driven search engine for all things
longevity and health Tech related and I
get my summaries and I get 10 to 12
articles per day and they are for me
consistently like the most important
breakthroughs on the planet I need to
know about and consume I created another
one also available for free for anybody
called um uh it's called
futureloop.com Uh future Loop and that's
looking at converging exponentials in
different Industries in transportation
in education in healthcare in all the
industries so it it's an AI engine
that's looking for and saying okay uh in
these particular Industries
um uh agriculture transport again a
whole bunch of them is there an article
about uh two or three exponentials
converging and then is it a positive
semantic I'm I can get all the negative
news I want from CNN so I have no
interest in that it has to be high a
high validity score positive semantic
and about converging exponentials two or
three exponentials coming together
because that's really where the
disruption's coming in it used to be a
single exponential Tech was enough but
it's really the convergence now two
three or four applied to a product to
service and Industry and so I mean
honestly
that's
that's I don't
have time to look at nor do I really
care what a particular editor wants to
feed me
um you know I couldn't pay me enough to
watch what CNN or fox wants to feed me
it's like I don't want to I don't want
to have them shape my neural net shape
my mind so
um so it's an unbiased view of all the
Breakthrough Technologies and then I I
dig in deeper in the articles that are
most interesting to me
where can we send people to find you on
the internet find the books that you've
written or learn more about some of the
companies You're Building sure so
um uh my podcast is called moonshots and
mindsets
um uh my if you go to diamandis.com I
put out all of my blogs there I put out
two technology blogs per week uh once on
on longevity and health Tech the other
ones on exponential Technologies
converging on Industries I'm actually
putting out a sequence right now uh
called metatrends I've basically
identified what I consider the top 20
meta Trends this decade they're going to
reshape every industry and so that's uh
part of my my blog and then Twitter it's
uh uh at Peter diamandis and same handle
on Instagram and and others so anyway uh
and then people who want my you know
abundance 360 is my year-round
Mastermind and coaching program that's
just abundance360.com Mike you know like
yourself I'm just I'm I want people to
realize we're living in the most
extraordinary time ever in human history
there's never been other than tomorrow
more exciting time to be alive and the
way you see the world
um uh can can be gone from disaster to
opportunity right from from scarcity to
abundance it really is your mindset that
makes the difference the way they see
the world and so
um you know with a positive mindset you
can create an extraordinary world and
all of us have the chance to uplift
Humanity more than ever before
I always enjoy learning and listening to
you because I think uh you've got just
this unique view of the world and uh
it's a world and a future that I want to
believe in that it is better than the
past that it is uh worth working on uh
and that it can improve people's lives
and I think that the uh kind of
persistent optimism uh is something that
everyone should aspire to have I'll say
one last thing for those who are like
that's [ __ ] how can you be
optimistic and everything's going on
with the Ukraine and then FTX and and
all of this stuff going listen here's
the deal if I were to ask you between
1900 and today has the world gotten
better
right
um and I would hope most people would
realize right the average age uh back
120 years ago was like 40 would die of
TB and and you would work 80 hour work
weeks to survive
um and access to education and Health
Care was de minimis and it was just you
know we we romanticized the past but it
was brutal life was brutal and short
back 120 years ago and we've made
massive strides between 1900 and today
and during that time we also had World
War One World War II the Spanish Flu the
Vietnam War you know we had massive
amount of hardship and death and so
forth but on the whole over the long
term life has improved
extraordinarily and so yes we're gonna
have ups and downs we're gonna have
challenges we're gonna have issues and
yes over the long term the life of your
kids and their kids is going to be
extraordinarily better than the lives we
have today
just we've got to be looking not in the
moment but over the long term and
realize that entrepreneurs today have
the power to do it only governments and
large corporations could ever do before
and I Define an entrepreneur someone who
finds a problem and solves a problem and
that's an amazing world to live in
there's no better way to end this
conversation than that Peter thank you
so much for your time and we'll
definitely do it again in the future my
pleasure my friend be well thanks